rest in peace milton
okay so up top i know a lot of you will
be here asking why i'm dropping this
because the movie isn't out in america
whenever i cover a film that has a
delayed release i normally get comments
like that so i thought i'd talk about
them right up front
and then we can get into the breakdown
and the movie is actually now out in the
uk
and a number of other countries though i
know some of you think i should wait
until it's released in the us
and are probably a sad peacemaker right
now i am a uk based channel
so sorry yeah i tend to go off release
dates here rather than in america
now for example green knight is now out
in the us but it's not out over here and
if people want to do ending explains on
that
then that's totally fine now by that i
mean i'm gonna shout out them in the
comments and thumbs down the video
and demand that they wait until i've
personally had a chance to see it
the scumbags making videos about movies
now i will say that suicide squad is an
incredible film and if you haven't seen
it yet then you really should save
yourself the surprises
because it's that good you should go
into this film as blind as possible as
it has some great twists as well as
character deaths
from here on out it's full spoilers
ahead and this
is your last warning turn around it's
your last warning
now the film focuses on an operation on
the island of corto maltese
in which task force x are called in to
destroy a tower called jottenheim
quarter maltese has featured in several
dc properties such as frank miller's the
dark knight returns
as well as batman 89 jotunheim is a name
that you might recognize from thor
namely as being the home of the frost
giants the name
actually pulls from nordic mythology and
it was one of the nine realms that was
home to a wealth of giants and colossal
beasts
in the film we discover that this is
actually a sign slab from the second
world war
which is being used to house the
telepathic alien star or the conqueror
starro first appeared in the brave and
the bowl 28 and since then he's gone on
to have a number of appearances in dc
comics
most of the inspiration in this
iteration seems to take influence from
grant morrison's seminal jla run
namely the first volume in which starro
appeared during the comics starro took
over a gigantic tower
and it was up to the justice league to
infiltrate it and take him down
or it i think it's it i don't know the
guy's gender or all women's gender
now it actually managed to capture most
of the members and put them under its
control
but batman saved the day using his brain
and it was really one of the first
comics that showed why he was as valued
as much as the other superheroes
now we learned that the us actually
captured the creature and that they set
up an alliance with the quarto maltesers
sorry malteseans in order to experiment
on their own people
the leaders of the country put both
political opponents
journalists and even children who were
all subjected to the hive mind
dc villain the thinker headed up this
operation and for 30 years he studied
the creature and forced people to become
a part of it
now after a military coup overthrows the
current dictatorship
the country is taken over by an
anti-american regime that wished to use
staro to thwart their enemies
while it ends up putting together a new
suicide squad to go in
and take down juttenheim and in doing
this they'll destroy all the evidence
that the us
participated in any of the experiments
now the team are led by bloodsport
played by idris elba we learn that he's
imprisoned for putting a kryptonite
bullet in superman
and this calls back to the comics as
being pretty much
the only thing that he's known for
bloodsport's daughter recently stole a
watch
and because of this willa blackmails him
by threatening to throw her in bel reeve
it was a really nice watch yeah to be
fair you could watch
tv on it hey like watch like watch tv
i'm not
i i said are you having that now this is
very much to the dismay of her
underlings
and we'll talk about how they play into
the post-credits scene later on in the
video
the other squad members include harley
quinn rick flag
peacemaker king shark ratcatcher 2
captain boomerang
polkadot man savant blackguard javelin
mongol weasel and also tdk
now weasel is played by sean gunn who
also cameos as calendar man in this
movie
now i hope no one is too attached to
these characters
as within the first five minutes most of
the group end up dead after black god
sells them out
captain boomerang gets a big death early
on and
weasel apparently drowns though we do
learn in the post-credits scene that the
character actually survived
personally i believe that he will be
appearing in the peacemaker hbo max
series
which we'll discuss as we get towards
the second post credit scene
the suicide squad what what is this
scarlett johansson's career
at disney hey because you're suing like
sue inside squash
now all this leaves us to select few and
holly is captured by the quarter maltese
forces
taken before the president she's told
that he wishes to marry her
as she will provide an anti-american
symbol that the country can unite behind
the two spend a wonderful day together
but after he mentions sending kids to
starro
she sees it as a red flag and then kills
him holly has come
a long way since the prior movies and
after her relationship with mr j
she decides to end any blossoming
romance as soon as a warning sign pops
up
so she just stamps down on him as fast
as she can
this leaves his second in command to
become president and he wants to launch
starro against russia
the us and also china the group managed
to catch back up with holly after she
escapes
and united with the force of freedom
fighters they capture the thinker and
head to yottenheim
they split up into teams with one side
going to the dirty little secret lab
whilst the others plant explosives
around the building
now this is where the truth is revealed
and rick flag decides to expose the
operation to the world
however peacemaker wants to keep the
peace and he knows that
if this info is brought to light it will
destabilize the country
thus he kills him and after rat katya
attempts to take the data
peacemaker catches up to her too and he
decides to execute her
now it's during this time that we see
the opposite side of the plan play out
and it's brilliant how the film
constantly flips back and forth between
perspectives
after detonating explosives bloodsport
crashes through the tower
and he ends up face to face with
peacemaker the pair both shoot at the
same time but bloodsport is able to have
his bullet travel through peacemakers
because he uses smaller ones if you're
watching this video without seeing the
movie then
i don't know what you're doing but the
pair are constantly trying to one-up
each other and at one point peacemaker
brags about being able to shoot through
blood sports bullet holes
without leaving a mark by using smaller
bullets now he takes one in the throw
like ryan airy's mom
but we learn in the post-credits scene
that he survives this
both of the two and stingers in the
movie center around two characters
thought to be dead
but the pair return and that is why i
think they'll both be showing up later
down the line
now if you're enjoying the video and
this is your first time here
and welcome to the heavy spoilers show i
am your host paul aka the guy who's
always got a do-or-die
job like the suicide squad and here we
break down lots of tv shows and movies
every single day
we'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
as it makes life easier
and also make sure you subscribe here or
i'll blow that thing that i put in your
neck
now after staro escapes walla tells
what's left of the group to return home
but the screams of the citizens being
taken over by starro
proved too much for them and they head
back in walla demands they go home
but they refuse and just as she's about
to detonate the explosives in their
necks
their staff knock her out we learn in
the post-credits scene that because of
this insubordination
that a pair of her underlings are forced
to look after peacemaker
who is recovering in the hospital the
two characters placed in charge of him
are called aggie and holland
and we know from behind the scenes info
that the pair are set to star on the
peacemaker series coming to hbo max
because of this i think that they will
very much be his handlers
and in the episodes that they'll appoint
him jobs which involves saving the
[ __ ] world
now peacemaker likely wants revenge
against bloodsport
and i actually think that they might
have idris elba featuring at some point
though this isn't confirmed they are
good at keeping things secret like the
taiko attitude cameo
in which he was revealed to be the
original rat catcher
nice little easter egg there now the
series is also set to explore
peacemaker's origins
i think this will heavily center around
his relationship with his father
who very much helped him to form his
mentality during the scene in which
bloodsport talks about how his dad
tortured him with rats
peacemaker lets off a smirk almost like
he can relate to him
and i think we will discover what made
this super patriot the way that he is
we know that robert patrick will be
playing the character's dad and with the
actor being in his 60s
i'm guessing that character will also
appear in the present as well as the
past
potentially the show could be about why
cena hasn't seen him in a while
which is ironic as normally cena is the
one who
isn't getting seen because weasel also
survives and shungum plays him
i can see his brother bringing him into
the series too i think he will be back
in some form or another
perhaps as comic relief now the movie
ends with this squad taking down starro
and it very much feels like a team
effort although it was hilarious how
throughout the movie that poked up man
saw his mother wherever he looked
and this made staro appear as a giant
middle-aged woman to him
sadly he's killed but he does become a
superhero in his final moments
which we learn is what his mother wanted
him to be king shark
chews starro holly jumps into its eye
and rat catcher 2
swarms the monster with memories of her
father rattling through her mind
about how if rats have a purpose then
everyone does
walla awakens and bloodsport threatens
to unleash the data from the drive to
the world
if she tries to kill him and because of
this they'll let brie
his daughter sees him on tv which she
isn't watching on a watch incidentally
and we end the movie with him petting
rat catcher 2's rat
showing that he's finally managed to
confront his childhood fear
now where the dc eu goes from here is
going to be very interesting to see
but i really hope that the movies are
this good going forward
this is one of my favorite comic book
films in a long time and it shows that
dc can be amazing when it's not trying
to mimic marvel
if all the studio is aspiring to be is
in line with them then they'll always
fall
short and i'm glad they just did a balls
to the wall action movie that doesn't
pull any punches when it comes to
character deaths
violence and gore however the movie also
has a heart
whereas marvel tend to downplay their
emotional scenes by
often ending with a joke this film
allows the dramatic moments to play out
so we can see the true sincerity in the
scenes so many of these characters are
incredible
especially ratcatcher 2 who i think is
this standout here
her relationship with king shark feels
very similar dynamic wise to killer
frost
and the character in assault and arkham
and it just adds so much that
i think really elevates the film margot
robbie also delivers her best
performance as harley quinn
and she adds so much more to the role
here than we've ever seen from her
before
idris albert does a fantastic job of
leading the cast and also
leaving his mark and shout outs joel
kinneman for finally getting to show us
what he can do with rick black everyone
is fantastic
and it's a testament to james gunn's
directing skills that he was able to
balance the tone perfectly
as well as the action and comedy it's a
movie that the more i think about the
more i love
i can't wait to watch it again it
perfectly captures just how frantic the
comics are
and feels like one of dc's best films to
date
the suicide squad was amazing and it
gets
a 9 out of 10. obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the film
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we are running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu box
sets on the 30th of august
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want some else
comic book related to watch then make
sure you check out our brighton black
widow which will be linked on screen
right now
we went over all the easter eggs in it
we could find and it's one of our best
videos i think
so definitely go watch it right after
this without the way thank you visiting
through this one i've been poor
i'll see you next time take care peace
maker